[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy to find practical
advice you can use in your
everyday life hi i'm dan haynes and i'm
joined by my co-host dr greg sadler
today we're talking about marcus
aurelius the stoic emperor
and his meditations and you might say
well why are we doing that
well you know we've we've talked about
stoicism quite a lot on this
show before and so we'll be you know
discussing some more
things having to do with that but
there's a very special anniversary
coming up that we're going to tell you
about
in just a minute but before that we want
to throw a little quote at you
that might seem a bit uncharacteristic
so dan go ahead and take it away so
the best revenge is to be unlike him who
performed
the injury you know this is
from the person that is literally the
most
powerful person in the world and could
easily
be you know cavalier and say like you
know
someone slighted me someone bumped into
me he could
like have them immediately executed he
had
absolute authority and and thus he is
somehow humble enough to look at this
and be
like so grounded is a very um
unlikely thing especially if you kind of
go along with
the old adage of you know a power
corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely how did this man who
was
the the literally could have his every
whim
catered to uh come out in
this sort of mindset yeah and there were
already
examples of previous roman emperors who
didn't withstand that corrosive tendency
of power and some of them actually
started out halfway decent
but you know by the end they they were
real
they're real scumbag some of them right
so yeah you're right aurelius he could
have uh
he could have gone the wrong way um he
could have gone bad
now we we should mention that his his uh
successor and son
um didn't turn out so good and that's
something that people bring up a lot but
you know i mean
you look at kids and you look at parents
it's
it's often quite difficult to pass on
precisely
what you want and i would imagine being
an emperor would be even tougher in some
ways
yeah and to like expand upon this he
often says
something to the effect of like soon you
will be dead and none of this will
matter
and and that seems so out of character
for what you think of
extremely powerful people that usually
have a pretty
you know strong ego and focused on their
legacy right
yeah or or just whatever's happening now
it's like yeah long term or short term
and and this is this is about a moment
in time
yeah so let's talk a little bit about
why we're focusing
on this guy um when we were getting
ready to
to start thinking this show out you
brought up gladiator and i was like yeah
i don't know if everybody out there
these days even remembers that because
movies age pretty quickly but i think
that for most people
if they do know marcus aurelius it is
from that movie where he
he has a bit part or not he does but you
know the the character that's written
into the script to portray him right
yeah just that little bit of pop culture
is i think it's it does him a disservice
it doesn't
really go into the character of the
person and you know you
if you're gonna look at emperors in that
movie yeah it's much more
commodus than anyone else that you see
as
that's true i mean what we get from the
movie is well he was a decent guy
and you know thought of everybody else
but that's about it we don't see
why that was the case and
you know you're right commodus gets to
be the the super villain
for the movie yeah in ways that he
wouldn't have been an ordinary life i
mean he did like to gladiate i suppose
you can call it
but i don't think he had vendettas
against russell crowe like
characters carried out for years and
years and years
so you know hollywood really likes to uh
mess around with things don't they but
that's that's why we should talk about
who this guy was because that you know
people might only have that impression
and we're going to talk about this book
called
typically the meditations that became a
really important part of stoic
literature
and right now it's it's kind of a hot
commodity right
well yeah it will specifically because
of an upcoming anniversary and there
this is going to be what is the 1900th
anniversary of his birthday coming up
here on
april 26th and so this is one of the the
progenitors of the show of like why
we're doing this today we're doing it a
little bit early granted but
we wanted to get ahead of the curve so
we could announce some of the things
that are coming up about
aurelius but i will say too with the
meditations there
are you know hundreds of thousands of
people
buying it reading it talking about it
and that's been going on for
for quite a while i remember when i was
at stoicon 2016 and ryan holiday
was the um the plenary speaker
and he was telling a bit of his story
and i didn't actually know that much
about his story because i'll confess to
you i don't actually read ryan
holliday's books very much
but um he was he was talking about
having gotten a copy of the meditations
when he was
in college and reading his way through
it and i think he had a much better
experience than i did reading it in
college
because it like changed his life and
then it you know
drove him to like get interested in
stoicism
and he he rereads it you know frequently
and i think there's a lot of people out
there like that
you know there's other important stoic
texts but i don't i don't hear that many
people saying yeah man i
re-read seneca's letters like once a
month
or epictetus discourses um whereas
people do say that about the meditations
i think part of it is that it's just
it's got
a almost poetic quality to parts of it
um as well as it's one of those things
that it's non-linear and thus
um you can kind of just drop in any
place that you want if you want to like
just
i don't know one of those readers or
like maybe
psalms or something along those lines of
dropping it and just finding something
that might be
uh useful or something to meditate upon
yourself that's a really interesting
point that maybe its lack of
systematicity is not a deficit on it on
its part but rather a strength of the
work
right yeah and and it just happens to be
like that it's not like he
set out to do that it was it was never
even
intended to be read by anyone it was it
was a
personal journal for his own thoughts in
his own
you know philosophical practice and and
by dearth of him being an emperor and
people retaining his writings
do we have this little piece of uh stoic
practice
yeah and we're going to tell a little
bit of that that story because it is
kind of a crazy story
uh when we get down to it so the the
like with a couple other texts i'm going
to give you a little teaser about this
it survived in just a few manuscripts
and if those manuscripts had been lost
that would have been it
a lot a lot of people don't know that
like beowulf
only had there were only two existing
copies at one time
if i remember the story right and if
those had disappeared that would have
been
it for that that entire work of
literature and it's the same thing for
for this one we should we should shift
gears a little bit and tell you a little
bit about these events that are
coming up uh so what's the ones that you
are going to be
participating in specifically well i'm
not
in on the the biggest event um
and let's talk about that one first okay
that way i can
you know i can get to my my stuff a
little bit later so
it's mostly the london people that are
doing this because the aurelius
foundation which there's a whole
foundation right named after this guy
now
devoted to bringing stoicism to
younger people the irelias foundation
and modern stoicism organization are
having this marcus aurelius anniversary
conference on sunday april 25th
and it begins kind of early for for us
because it's it's on london time
but there's a lot of speakers and it
looks like a really great lineup
same day there's the new acropolis
chicago is having a thing they're
calling roman banquet celebrating marcus
aurelius's
1900 years of legacy and i'll be
presenting during that on marcus
aurelius on
anger and then jalad will will be
presenting on on some other features of
marcus aurelius and that's a little bit
of a smaller event
and then a little bit before that here
in milwaukee
um we're putting on that's when i say we
me and my wife and partner andy shaka
we're going to be putting on a little
thing about how to read marcus aurelius
as a beginner so you know what to look
for
what to not allow to take you off course
you know what questions
naturally arise all those sorts of
things that's more of a workshop than a
talk where i'll be doing
a lot of q a with with people so and you
know i actually did search
and i didn't find anything else
that was coming up i don't know did you
see anything else
online about uh other marcos aurelius
events
nothing specifically nothing more than
what you've outlined here but i bet
that if anything else drops in then you
can find it on the stoicism today blog
maybe uh i can't promise that i would
actually like look in meetup or
and in other things that have like
groups um
maybe maybe there'll be announcements
that people haven't gotten out quite yet
right well i will say one other thing
that's kind of cool and i think it might
be too late for people to get in on it
there was a poetry contest for people to
write
short i think like 250 words or less
poems that are themed around marcus
aurelius and some people submitted some
limericks
and things like that but there were some
other other entries and i i guess
i'm not on the committee for that but
modern stoicism got quite a few really
good
entries and so those are going to get
well
the top one is going to get read during
the conference
i think by the person who wrote it and
then
um some of the other really good ones
we're going to publish in the in the
stoicism today blog so i i think that
you know that's that's an idea i would
have never come up with on my own you
know
but it was a really cool idea i think it
would it might have been john sellers or
it might have been
tim labon who came up with it but
whoever did it's it's
it's a brilliant idea to get more people
involved in
in doing this and doing it in a way that
we wouldn't normally think about you
know
like philosophical treatises that's one
thing poetry that's a whole
whole different animal right you know
and uh
good luck to all of the uh cunning
linguists who are going to join us on
that
yeah so what we're going to do today
the bulk of this show other than the
chatting that we've already been doing
is going to be talking about like
insights and practices from marcus
aurelius that that you can use because
the show is supposed to be about
you know um applying philosophy to
everyday life so this guy is a
philosopher as well as a
a emperor but we're also going to talk
about um
why marcus and the meditations is
important for modern stoicism
who this guy was a bit more biography
and and context dan and i each have a
little story about
how we got into the meditations and what
we got out of it i'm going to mention
too by the way
that dan um he brought
what we call stoic walking talks here to
milwaukee
from was it the fremont stoa yeah yeah
in california and the first things that
that you were doing if i remember right
was marcus aurelius's
meditations uh reading portions of it
and then walking along lake park
is that it is oh uh lake elizabeth
okay like elizabeth there or here
oh sorry in california it's like
elizabeth here yes
lake park yeah yeah and so it was it was
kind of cool to do i'd never done
anything like that before but it's you
know you you
walk along in this beautiful natural
environment something that marcus was
particularly attuned to
and talk about stoicism and marcus
aurelius and some passages i thought it
was a really cool thing to do
so we're gonna we're gonna talk about
how we got into it and then
we'll talk also about um what the book
is and
a bit of its history uh a little teaser
you know that i gave you of earlier
and then then we're gonna jump into all
those insights and practices and
we're going to you know just run through
as many as we can we're both a bit
loquacious
so i don't know how many we'll actually
get to
ah it's not getting through them it's
journey right
yeah and we could always i suppose we
could always pick up more down the line
you know we could do a
marcus take two right
well we've got uh april of next year so
that's true yeah yeah well and you know
if we're still doing the show 100 years
from now then it will be the really big
anniversary
oh yeah there'll be two uh heads and
jars right
exactly like on futurama right
[Laughter]
so so let's talk a little bit about um
modern stoicism and and marcus and i
think
we probably um should talk a little bit
first about well what is stoicism
because we can't presume that everybody
listening to this
has listened to every single show or
anything along those lines so
you know there's there's a number of
important
ideas what would you say are the most
simple and straightforward ways of
talking about what stoicism is
um i'd say it is a virtue ethic
um so as uh i i would call it for most
a uh
wow um a philosophy of a moral
philosophy um
as well as a orientation towards the
world in how
you view it and how you are interacting
with it
which then has certain thoughts that
derive from the
the values and so some of the basic
values are
that those things that are actually
valuable are those things that
we actually have full control over and
those
in the stoic sense are really a very
small subset of
everything um it's not that we don't
have influence over other things but
there's only some things that we have
total control over and those include our
desires
our aversions the opposite of our
desires
and our
movement towards something and our
movement away from something
and on to a certain extent our thoughts
our you know we also have some control
over our emotions it's not as if we can
like you know
turn them on or off with a switch but i
mean one of the things that is very
liberating about
stoicism is this realization that i
don't i don't have to be angry i don't
have to be sad i don't have to be
fearful although there could be you know
the right amount of fear
in some cases um and
and my thoughts lead to why i feel the
way that i
i do um so yeah that's i mean there's a
lot more to stoicism that we could talk
about but that's that's a good thumbnail
sketch
um now when we talk about this term
modern stoicism
something that that dan and i are both
you know pretty closely involved in
we're talking about taking ancient
stoicism as
a philosophical school and trying to
adapt it to
to modern life so there's some things
that end up kind of going by the wayside
you know the notion that the whole
universe is
one vast rational
what you can't even call it creature
because it didn't create nobody created
it but but that it's one
it's essentially like god's mind i think
most of us
leave that aside um also uh
the fact that or the not the the thought
that they had of like
the universe going through cycles and
everything burning up and then
recomposing and
happening over and over exactly the same
way every time
that one's a tough one to stick with i
mean there are some people who do
believe that sort of thing but those are
more the traditional stoics
um and there's other aspects too where
it's more culturally conditioned
epictetus thought that
if you were a man and you didn't have a
beard there was something wrong with you
very very insistent about you know
traditional gender roles i think we
were probably a lot more flexible with
those sorts of things but
you know um stoicism is is a lifestyle
that's being practiced by people and
it's
also being stud studied academically
and you know we can talk about this
revival that's been going on
i don't know what would you say about 25
30 years
it's been picking up more and more steam
uh in the last decade or so yeah and
i wanted to say something about this
idea of marcus australius being a
philosopher and how
people that are practitioners of like
modern stoicism
um would be considered philosophers in
the more ancient contexts of the
philosopher
and it's not like marcus is sitting and
writing treatises about how
you know from some certain
beginning axioms to then uh like come to
some conclusion
he is a practitioner of a
certain set of values um which is called
the philosophy
and and those people that are followers
are then considered
a philosopher in this context yeah one
of the
definitions that you see in stoic texts
of philosophy is the
art or the craft the techne of living
the idea is that it's i mean there is a
very intellectual side to it not lots of
theory
unfortunately much of which has been
lost um
because it would be kind of cool to look
at it but you don't you don't absolutely
need that stuff in order to
live the philosophy out and to reap the
benefits of it
right and you know there are people that
are
currently doing the more you know ivory
tower-esque
things of building some of that
like uh text back out you know like if
you start from certain
uh values or axioms that are kind of
like the foundation of stoicism you can
then
apply these to larger and larger systems
and see how
these things would work under this
particular set of
original values yeah you know i'll
actually mention a few
of my um colleagues and friends who are
doing that sort of thing
particularly in terms of the environment
which i think is is
really quite important um one of them is
kai whiting
who is a british guy who was in portugal
for a while
uh does a lot of work on sustainability
along with his his uh
friend and uh co-author um
leo constantinis i think i mean
i'm sure i mangled his name they have a
new book out um by the way
and uh christopher gill uh sort of the
the grandfather of the modern stoic
movement in many ways
or maybe it has maybe it has several you
know lawrence becker
uh and uh a long and uh
julia on us and a few others would be
you know
all grandparents together yeah
but um you know
chris gill is doing a lot of stuff on
stoicism and environmentalism and i
think that's
that's quite important um because you
know
we're thinking in a cosmic way about
the place of humanity in
the cosmos and trying not to wreck it
for humanity hopefully yeah
so let's let's talk a little bit more
about this particular
guy in this this book so marcus's
meditations
are very popular they're read by a lot
of people
in stoic groups and on their own
i think part of that is because he's a
he's a bit of an
easier read than say epictetus
discourses
or seneca's letters or cicero's texts
and
we don't really have that many big books
to choose from
for classic stoicism so marcus
is kind of at a i mean would you say
he's at a beginner level or like
beginner intermediate
there's there's a lot of really deep
stuff in there but
it yeah a lot of it is really easy to at
least
pick up and understand um especially
because they're they're often very
very bite-sized little bits of
information or practice
and yeah i think one of the things that
is
the most useful or most salient in
the meditations is he is describes a lot
of
uh philosophical practices and whereas
the others
tend to be a little bit more um
you know with theory uh like talk about
it but he's always like okay well i need
to do this i need to wake up the morning
and i do this i need to
look at these things in this way i need
to and it's it's very
easy because it just gives it like lays
out what he was supposed to be doing
and how he should be orienting himself
on everyday
experiences you know before we get into
his biography which i know you want to
talk about a good bit
so is marcus more relatable
than epictetus and seneca in a way
because he he's addressing himself i
mean epictetus
and seneca are addressing people that we
could like put ourselves into the place
of like epictetus students or
seneca's whoever the letter's written to
usually lucilius
marcus is talking directly to himself
and he's talking to himself as somebody
who should be doing better but is often
screwing up
and it's like you know when you talk to
the person who's got potential and
they're not living up to their potential
he's talking to himself that way
i mean does that make it easier for the
rest of us to kind of fit ourselves into
that book
i think he's definitely goading himself
to be better
but it's done with a little bit more
kindness than when you see epictetus
who loves to like you know call out
people and say like you're a slave
and yeah which is kind of a full slave
that's
a harsh on like kind of smack over the
top of the head
versus marcus is like this is i really
need to be doing this and which
i don't know depending on the person uh
that orientation might be a little bit
easier to get into
yeah you know it's it's interesting
because somebody could say oh well
that's just because epictetus was
talking to his students
but when you read the discourses no he
talks to everybody that way
he talks to a roman pro curator which is
you know like
a pretty high level position the guy
comes in and he's complaining about a
crowd
not liking what he said and epictetus is
basically saying listen dummy
you know to him too
so yeah yeah
well why don't you why don't you uh lead
us through some of the
um important points of biography that
you you thought were
yeah so like the big thing is or
here's the the last in line of what has
been dubbed the five good emperors
and one of the things that made them the
good emperors
is that they weren't actually uh the
heretical
children of the the previous emperor and
so they had all been
adopting promising
well-adjusted individuals to succeed
them
and unfortunately for i guess the roman
empire
and the end of the pox armada um
marcus did not continue on with that so
if there's a
a big black mark against him that might
be one of the largest
um and but he was uh adopted by emperor
antonius pius um but he was uh fathered
by
marcus ennius varus um
and and he was like well known that he
was taught philosophy from very very
young age
he excelled at it and he he often
refers to the discourses which he
sometimes is referred to as like the
memoir
um and you can see him
his orientation towards socialism is
very
aligned with like epictetus's
construction of how to teach stoicism
with
his three uh disciplines of action on
uh desire and
acceptance and
to uh and you can see that
being expanded on in in the rest of the
the
meditations and how it is written as a
lot of times is oriented towards these
particular disciplines
yeah uh and but one of the things that
like
why he might have chosen um his
uh son to be emperor instead of choosing
a
adopted child is that he had 13
children with his wife but uh eight of
them died before he did and so he went
through a lot of grief of
like losing all these children and might
have created him
a position where he was a little bit
more
uh attached to his children which is
kind of funny from a stoke perspective
because that is one of the
ideas is to not be super attached to
those things that are physical in the
world that those
are not the things that are the most um
uh good they're they're not actually
technically a good within the
philosophy of stoicism they're preferred
and different
um but you know no one said that uh
marcus aurelius was a sage
he was just a practitioner and we all
tried to aspire to say yeah
but very few of us or none of us will
ever actually get there
yeah um go ahead i was just gonna
add that uh the meditations were written
on
later on in his life on while he was on
campaign for the most part in his uh mid
50s
and and so this is like a man who's like
the book is written as someone who's
seen a lot who's seen a lot of his
children die who has spent a lot of his
life
on campaign um fighting against uh
people that would
uh be rebellious against rome and had to
put down a
uh an upstart who was trying to claim
the emperorship
and also had a whole bunch of you know
i guess they would call them uh
barbarian tribes in the northwest
to yeah to squel but he
as emperor had a position of like he had
to
um as part of being the emperor to
protect um the the people and so that
was his job and
even though he probably didn't super
enjoy being on campaign for the
majority of his emperorship you know
when he could be in rome and just be
pampered if you really wanted to yeah or
just not be like you know sick and and
wet
and you know cold and all those sorts of
things
yeah i would rather be on the
mediterranean than way up in north and
like germany and um
and yeah just like when you read this
you know
this is this is a man who even in his
mid-50s seen a lot how uh the weight of
the world placed upon him
is still trying to become a better
person every day
that's that's really quite interesting
isn't it um
there would be so many opportunities to
just take it easy
and justify that to yourself and there'd
be people like you know standing next to
you would be like yeah
man take you take a day off uh you've
earned it you know look at look at all
the stuff that you've done
so far um it would really take
a lot of drive to be able to
persevere and that that is you know the
stoics
one of the key virtues is courage
and one of the parts of courage it isn't
just about facing fears it's about
persevering it's about like making the
right choice over and over and over
again
even when it gets difficult and you're
slogging along and you're tempted to
give in and and
relax and he he didn't i mean i'm sure
he did at some point but
um you know he's he's quite a model for
us i think
you know it's a i guess a model of
resilience and and faces yeah
like that's yeah unending challenges
that's a really great term to use um
and that's also associated with stoicism
resilience you know we know that
practicing stoicism does improve a
person's resilience it may not turn it
into like
super heroic levels but it advances us
along so that we can
be more able to do the things that are
good for us
and good for other people yeah that's
the whole uh epictetus talking about
come
i will teach you how to be invincible
what does that mean in the stomach sense
only not not don't enter contests that
you can't win
right in part right yeah and hey so
switching topics how did you get into
reading
the meditations because by the time that
i knew you you'd read it through a
number of times you were using it
you know like i mentioned as as the key
text for the stoic walk-in talks
what got you into and what did you get
out of the book
um let's see i
i got into stoicism and and started
learning a little bit about it through a
couple like podcasts like matt banetta's
good fortune podcast
um and that was like my gateway into
actually
starting to read the ancients and and
the meditations was just the first thing
that
i picked up i happened to pick up the uh
the gregory hayes version
maybe i had a which is good yeah maybe i
had an affinity with the name
i don't know
[Laughter]
um but at least his translation is
it flows very nicely not that it is the
definitive translation and there are
many to choose from and uh and
i guess the only really definitive
meditations is in the greek
yeah and and you know the
text there's only a few manuscripts left
uh
that are that are pretty old you know we
don't have any original of course
um wouldn't that be a fine to have the
prototype copy of
the meditations but how would we know
that it was you know right
um yeah you know i i have here
uh with me the um the book that i got
when i was in college and i think i
picked this
up at a used bookstore i think actually
it was half price
in in milwaukee so it's it's the the
meditations
um that i had and it's by
the names in this translated by the late
asl farquhar sun
and then with the introduction of notes
by rutherford
um so that that's an older translation
to be sure and hayes is way better than
than this one but it's um you know i i
picked it up and i
you know i i had no interest in stoicism
at the time
and i didn't really know much about
stoicism
as an undergraduate philosophy major
because the only thing they actually had
us read was epictetus and caridian and
they told us
stoicism doesn't really matter it was
you know all aristotle and plato and
then everything went downhill
from them in ancient philosophy which is
which is a wrong-headed take and we
could talk about that some other time
and i remember reading through it and i
probably understood
maybe a quarter of what i was reading as
an undergrad
and it went on my shelf and it traveled
around with me and then
as i got more into stoicism through
through reading epictetus discourses
i picked up the meditations and then
suddenly things clicked and i was like
oh yeah that
that's that's what he's talking about
there because the
you know um marcus is you could say
traveling in the footsteps of epictetus
in in many respects i guess i would
would like to add like i picked up this
book
or sorry this particular copy my uh
gregory hayes version
yeah in in austin texas at uh there's a
little
uh independent bookstore there i guess
it's not particularly do you want to
plug them
i can't remember what it is anymore i
would i would but i bought two copies
uh i bought this copy and i bought the
same time i bought a different
translation yeah at the same time
and i started reading it i really liked
it and on my way
out of austin i was going to grab a
flight
and i stopped in at a restaurant um
had i just sat at the bar i struck up a
conversation with
the barman and um by the
end of the conversation i had gifted him
the other copy of my meditations
nice um and then and then for this i
like i
i came home and uh i spent
i i was i wasn't working full time at
that moment in time and so i
i just went to a coffee shop and i
devoured this thing
and because it just it spoke to me in a
such a like
yes yes once like over and over again
like that
it was like digging into my own
mind and my own psyche and like yes like
i hadn't been able to articulate these
things until i saw it
in this particular form and you know if
you if you can see it here
it's just yeah annotated it to the nines
now that's a that's a really
great point about reading and
about important texts you know we
i don't want to say that we read and we
read justifying things that confirm our
viewpoint
because some people do do that and and
that's not the best way to read
but there's there is a different
experience the one that you just talked
about
where you you know you've got some ideas
and they're not
quite worked out and you're not sure how
they fit together
and somebody else comes along and lays
them out and you're like yeah that's
exactly what i was what i was
driving at i just didn't have the i
didn't have the structure i didn't know
the vocabulary
i wasn't sure what i was trying to say
but this is somebody who actually knows
what the hell they're talking about and
this is it right yeah
i've had that experience many times
and it's kind of funny because we often
think about philosophers are supposed to
like you know not
not take anything for granted don't
don't buy into anybody else's stuff
but i think that that's a normal
experience this
clicking with with somebody and the book
you know the book informing us
and helping to structure our own
thinking our own living
in ways that we're not able to pull off
at the time
yeah i think i've only only a couple of
the times like
some of the existentialist texts have
really like
clicked interesting
is i mean we've talked about them quite
a bit uh on the show is that why
you keep coming back to certain key
authors like uh
jean paul sartre and simone de beauvoir
and
and yeah speak
to some of my really core values
well that makes sense and there are
interesting compatibilities that we
uh have explored in previous shows
including the last show
between stoicism and existentialism
so yeah that makes that does make a lot
of sense
i do want to say just a few things about
the meditations as a book before we jump
into our our promised
insights and and practices so as dan
pointed out there is no like best or
definitive translation there are some
that are not
quite as good you can say um and it is
you know we call it the meditations the
greek is
heyaltone literally things to oneself
and it is marcus talking to
himself um and it's it's divided into 12
you know you can call them books they
were originally scrolls or chapters
um there isn't any particular thematic
unity except for the first book which is
all about i'm grateful to this person
i'm grateful to this person i think
that's kind of a cool way
to start and the manuscripts
you know they mostly only existed in the
east for a long time it was written in
greek
it kind of disappeared from the west and
it was in the byzantine empire
and then as the the ottoman turks were
destroying what was left of the
byzantine empire all these books started
flowing
west and um eventually
you know it they were lucky they got
there when the printing press was in
full swing and
they started printing copies of it so it
didn't have quite the influence
like on the the middle ages and
the early renaissance um
that say epictetus or seneca did
epictetus you know the discourses were
were lost and then found again for the
west but they had the end caribbean
seneca they had all this stuff the
entire time
and so you know it becomes you know a
representative stoic text but it was
always kind of like
you might say on the side and i think
it's it's coming to its own more
recently so um maybe there's something
to modern stoicism
and this this emphasis on on you know
using this as a
central text so that's
uh that's a good lead into well what do
we actually get out of
these texts um you know there's a lot of
really cool insights
as dan has pointed out there's a lot of
practices like right there
on the page one that i think is very
characteristic of
of marcus is the looking at things in a
cosmic perspective
and distancing ourselves he he suggests
that we should
take this perspective that locates us
within
space and time and we can say oh yeah
well i know exactly where i am i'm right
here
and i'm right now but but like putting
it in in context of
all the other hears and nows that have
been
and are now gone so he says at one point
the speed with which all of them
vanish the objects in the world and the
memory of them in time
this is to suggest to us that you know
maybe there's some things we don't have
to take quite so seriously
a little bit later he says some things
are rushing into existence
others out of it some of what now exists
is already gone
change and flux constantly remake the
world just as the incessant progression
of time
remakes eternity that's i like that
phrase
remaking eternity eternity itself we
usually think of the eternal
totally unchanging it's forever even the
eternal for
for marcus is influx and changing
right i wonder if that is based in the
the stoic physics of like the
the the constant destruction and
recreation of the universe
right the ecperosis right
yeah or the conflagration i think you've
got that
but you've also got this sense that i
mean it could be
millions of years until the next cycle
and everything is being eroded
everything is being
changed in the process he's got this
other really great
passage where he says if you want to
talk about people you need to look down
on the earth from above
herds armies farms weddings divorces
births deaths noisy courtrooms desert
places
all the foreign peoples holidays days of
morning market days
all mixed together a harmony of
opposites
look at the past empire succeeding
empire and from that
extrapolate the future the same thing no
escape
from the rhythm of events and so the
idea is
look how this vast variety of stuff
and now you're going to see the same
stuff happen over and over again
weddings are going to be happening
throughout time i mean we might call
them something different
you know we're in a very experimental
time we're like you know
hey everybody can get married uh because
you know everybody can
have uh just as uh rough you know set of
relationships as everybody else and the
divorce rate's like 50
so obviously marriages are not all that
that enduring
but this this uh institution of
people coming together and saying we're
going to live a life together
it's probably going to exist throughout
eternity and
it's going to take on all these
different little forms you know how we
produce our food you know may not be a
farm it might be
something else but it's gonna you know
there's gonna be something going on and
this vast variety helps to
contextualize the importance that we
we ascribed everything in in our life
you know
right i i like you know from
the taxi he kind of walks you through
some of these practices
and yeah yeah he takes it slow and like
first is like okay
i'll look at at if you're having a
conversation with another person
step back and and what what do you two
look like
from you know the guy you know 100 feet
away
okay well you know now you're you're
have this distance from the person and
so
uh you might be if you're in the middle
of the conversation you might be heated
and you the entire world is just
you and him at that one moment in time
you step back and
you see this and then you step back
again maybe from the the perspective of
a bird and now you're like kind of two
small dots
on the the the grass you know
a plane that you see and then you can
continue this up and take this to
okay well expand out and now you're at
like
the level of the you know iss or
something
and so you're looking down and you can't
see any people anymore everyone's just
it's just a blue brown of blotches on a
big blue orb yeah and uh and then you
can then step again okay look look all
the way back in time from
the beginning of time to now how much
time has passed
how much does the moment here actually
matter
and then also continue that time on till
the end of time
and you can really put into perspective
the how small this moment is and
kind of take the ability to step back
and and fully comprehend
yeah they there's a a name that modern
stokes give that they call it the view
from above where you
like deliberately visualize
going through that and it really does
help to produce
perspective i i would say there is a
challenge that's kind of associated with
this
of so if you do that right you can say
oh man nothing i do
matters at all because it's all just
going to get you know swallowed up in
this vast cosmos
so maybe i should just be a complete
bastard and do anything i like or
you know maybe nothing i do matters at
all but i i don't think that's where
marcus
wants us to go with that i think he
wants us to realize
both the you know that we're
a little point within a vast cosmos but
also that what we do
and the choices that we make in the
little tiny purview that we have do
matter
you know so if i if i do get heated do i
call my um i don't make it my
my uh uh sister right do i call her
a jerk or something like that or
you know should this allow me to become
less heated in the conversation
i think that's that's the way to look at
it what do you think it
it reminds me strongly of the pale blue
dots
and as the voyager spacecraft was
just about to turn off its camera carl
sagan said
turn turn it around and take one shot of
us
and yeah there's a a small i don't know
poem or stanza
uh look again at that dot they're here
that's home that's us on it everyone you
love everyone you know everyone you've
ever heard of every human being who was
ever was lived out their lives the
aggregate of our joy and suffering
thousands of confident religions
ideologies and economic doctrine
every hunter and forager every hero and
coward every
creator and destroyer of civilization
every king
and peasant every young couple and love
every mother and father
hopeful child inventor explorer every
teacher of morals every corrupt
politician
every superstar every supreme leader
every saint and sinner in the history of
our species
lived there on a mode of dust suspended
in a sunbeam
yeah that's that's a that's a great
uh passage for again
you know putting things in context i
would say a lot of
stoicism as well as other intentional
ways of
of living are very oriented towards
restoring a perspective that ought to be
there but often gets lost for us right
it does it does yeah
um it you know one of the people that we
we didn't talk about in this but i i
think we could actually recommend his
book piera doe
um he has this book the inner citadel on
marcus aurelius that is quite good
and and it makes those connections that
you were talking about between what
marcus is doing
and the three disciplines very
explicitly
he talks about this cosmic significance
and says that philosophy is a way of
life that's that should be one of the
vital dimensions not just not just doing
practical things like figuring out how
to not get angry
or you know balance our checkbooks but
also like thinking about the
uh the nature of the universe and where
we fit into it
so yeah so let's talk about another
yeah um so deconstruction of things in
yourself
um and so several times over the course
of the
uh meditations marcus comes back to this
idea of
deconstructing things and trying to
figure out like why you have an affinity
for them
both physical things as well as you know
your own mind and how you
think about things and why you think
certain things
so we can become blinded by things over
time because we don't examine what they
fully contain once one pulls back the
cover and looks at
what thing is actually in each of its
parts
uh one has a fuller understanding of why
things do
what they do and we gain new perspective
and so he he he's talking about at least
uh in the the physical sense of
uh deconstructing the food at a banquet
and it's like okay i
like this like this is really tasty i'm
having a great time
but it's like okay let's take a step
back why do i like this you know if i
really look at these things i i see um
uh seething uh like seeing roasted meat
and other dishes in front of you and you
suddenly realize
this is a dead fish or a dead bird or a
dead pig
or this noble vintage is
just grape juice and the purple robes
are sheep
wool died and uh shellfish blood and you
have to get those
purples and uh are
like this is one of the reasons why like
i i very much enjoy coffee i drink it
almost every morning but i've been uh
recently referring to
especially in my stoke group as we are
talking in the morning
it's like oh yes my hot bean juice yeah
because i gotta deconstruct that yeah
it's interesting if we don't
have um if we're only looking at like
one aspect of a thing
it's very easy for us to not only
be attracted to it but take way too much
of it and and
value it too much in relation to other
things
and and we live in a world where most
people actually don't
have much idea where their food is
coming from and we also live
in a world where the food has been
doctored and changed so much to look in
certain ways i mean think about oranges
for example right
you know they have they all have that
orange color because they're dyed orange
they they bleach them and then they dye
them you know
um i mean they still have the nice
orangey smell but um
and we could go on and on and on with
things that the food industry does to
try to make things more and more
attractive to us you know here's a
here's another great example if you want
to drink less
soda in the day because drinking soda
isn't good for you
call it what it is liquid candy because
that's what
that's all soda is carbonated candy it's
like 40
sugar yeah uh
yeah the another thing that reminds me
of this is on
dinosaur shaped uh chicken nuggets
as like how totally removed from the
reality of the situation
is that
um so he also then continues on this
with
uh like things that are actually in our
own mind
and so um why are we distressed by
things we need to like kind of
deconstruct
okay i have an emotion an emotion
emerges
arises why am i feeling that instead of
just going
like well now i'm angry or now i'm sad
or whatever you know like wha
what in this thing actually is causing
me
these things and is that a a rational
thing for me to be giving into and so he
talks
um if you are distressed by anything
external
the pain is not due to the thing itself
but to your
estimate of it and this you have the
power to revoke at any moment
and so someone someone cuts you off or
someone insults you
like if someone insulted a rock the rock
wouldn't have a problem with it
it's only you thinking that you have
some like reputation or like that
doesn't
uh equate with the idea that you have
within your own mind
that you now have a problem with it and
you are upset because it doesn't fit in
with the
world that you see yeah
now what if somebody objected and
they're like this is going to take all
the mystery and fun out of life
all you people just want to deconstruct
everything and
tear everything apart what do
i mean i think marcus could have a
response to that what do you think it
would be
um i i would
make my guess that uh in order to
actually do what
is good which is virtue and to
the actions that are actually have that
quality of virtue
you need to know what things actually
are in order to
act towards them in the correct manner
so in order to be wise in order to be
just yeah that makes sense
i mean do you think that you could say
listen when you
do unpack these things you're not taking
away beauty
you're not taking away mystery because
you go a level down and it's still
pretty mysterious
you know like you know i i went through
computer science in college
and and i know actually how computers
work down to like you know individual
transistors
um and like they're not magical anymore
but i love them more so by knowing all
that detail
and and that allows me to do so much
more
now that i know yeah yeah that's that
that's a great example
because uh computer science is so
analytically based
um i mean you're literally at the very
bottom level
a whole bunch of switches right right
you know it's just a whole bunch of uh
logic gates
and everything builds up from there and
or not
yep well let's let's talk about another
one that's that's kind of related to
this so
making use of bad things or bad
experiences
marcus suggests that we can reframe
things and
actually epictetus says something very
similar that we can
take we can turn everything to our
advantage
so marcus says it's unfortunate that
this has happened
no it's fortunate that this has happened
and i've remained unharmed by it
not shattered by the present or
frightened of the future it could have
happened to anyone
but not everyone could have remained
unharmed by
it why treat the one is a misfortune
rather than the other is fortunate
can you really call something a
misfortune that doesn't violate human
nature
so he's talking about like maybe getting
insulted or cut off in traffic or
something like that we don't have to
take that
as a calamity we can actually say well
this is an opportunity for me to
use virtue and so he says does what
happened
keep you from acting with justice
generosity self-control
sanity prudence honesty humility
straightforwardness and
all the other qualities that allow a
person's nature to fulfill itself and
so we can we can say this about you know
really anything you lost a job
uh you know a client flaked out on you
um you know you go out on a date and the
date doesn't
go well we could go down you know the
line you get sick
um everything can be turned into an
occasion
to instead of moaning and saying oh this
is awful to do something good
right yeah but take it
go ahead it's it's kind of distilled
down to
this like little at hand idea um
of misfortune born nobly is good fortune
that you can
turn any thing that would be seen by
you know an outsider as you know
oh no like this this thing has befallen
me
but no i'm the only one that is in
control of my actions
and within socialism virtue is the only
good
and my actions are the way that i'm
expressing my virtue and
those things are outside of me they're
they're not neither good nor bad
i'm the only ones that's controlling
these good or bad things and so
every time that i have a challenge is
another
chance for me to do the good
i think it's very liberating to realize
that we we do in fact have a choice in
these matters
you know because so many people get into
situations they're like oh things have
to go this way and and this has to
you know this must mean this and it's
like there's a logic to it but it's a
logic that's almost like
you know they don't realize it's a
loosey-goosey logic
right it's the sort of thing like if you
shook it some of the parts would fall
out
they think it's all like totally rigid
and things like this
suggest or passages like this suggest to
us that no no it's not it's not that
rigid at all this also reminds me of
another uh phrase from marcus that comes
up you know the
the obstacle right yeah absolutely
exactly so the obstacle presents itself
to us and now we can
we can respond to it and if we didn't
have the obstacle
you know the other stoics say stuff like
this as well if we don't have
things that are challenges to us we're
not going to be able to grow we're not
going to be able to
be courageous or show other
um show other aspects of
of virtue like justice or prudence
so it doesn't say to go directly into
the deep end
not you know if you're practicing you
don't go like well i'm gonna go and like
uh become a plea complete aesthetic and
go live in the wilderness or something
because that's the obstacle and i'm
gonna overcome it yeah yeah
take babies yeah right well
we're almost at the end of our our time
so we're gonna
let dan lead you out with something
quite amped here
yes well i'm gonna leave you the words
of marcus aurelius
the things ordained to you teach
yourself to be
at one with those and the people
who share them with you treat them with
love
with real love
[Music]
you